[Musique]
après une brillante carrière de joueuse
de tennis de très haut niveau à la
délaisser la terre battue pour les micro
de rmc où elle anime notamment les
grandes gueules du sport c'est l'invité
de ce nouveau numéro 2 par 78 sarah
pitkowski mais couverte le golf du mois
c'est le golfe
isabella situé sur la commune de plaisir
c'est un modèle de golf privé associatif
rencontre si au lieu de dix huit ou de
neuf trous nous allions jouer en payant
au nombre de trous effectués c'est
l'idée révolutionnaire d'olivier
d'hôtels et de son application eagle à
l'occasion de l'international golfweek
la célèbre compétition du golf national
rencontre avec un sponsor stéphane de
cayeux et avec le golfeur sans doute le
plus spectaculaire du monde david
edwards
[Musique]
l'été championne de tennis elle est
aujourd'hui consultant pour bfm tv
elle présente les grandes gueules du
sport sur rmc pour le golf s'occupe de
la communication notamment de la
fédération française de golf pour l'open
de france c'est notre invité de parts
soit 118 sarah pitkowski sarah pitkowski
bonjour alors je suis ravi de vous nous
rencontrer de vous ayez accepté d'être
l'invité de cette émission pour ceux qui
vous connaîtraient pas je rappelle vous
avez été championne de tennis
aujourd'hui vous êtes journaliste vous
animez les grandes gueules du sport sur
rmc vous êtes aussi une consultante et
10 pour bfm et puis vous occupez de golf
on va parler tout ça on va commencer un
peu quand même parle par le tennis vous
avez été dans les 20 meilleurs joueur
mondial oui oui je suis extrêmement
surprise mais j'ai été j'ai été dans les
20 meilleures mondiales
mais on ça se compte en années on a dit
oui d'accord mais alors ça a commencé
comment vous avez commencé très jeune je
suppose de tennis j'ai commencé à 7 ans
comme un certain nombre d'enfants à
l'époque il y avait une porte de garage
et donc j'ai beaucoup frappée contre la
porte de garage avec mes parents me
disent on va peut-être aller sur le
terrain de tennis
c'est exactement et comment commander
sida un moment qu'on va en faire un peu
son métier parce que ça a été ça va ça a
été des enchaînements de curiosité c'est
à dire que quand on gagne des tournois
on gagne des des belles victoires
on se dit bon on essaye toujours un
petit peu plus et puis on à la
fédération qui est extrêmement bien
organisé qui vous fait qui vous amène
dans des rassemblements et puis on
on laisse entendre à vous à vos parents
que ba qui a du potentiel donc on se dit
bon on essaye ça a été une succession de
portes que j'ai voulu ouvrir et puis à
18 ans après un bac bien rater je me
suis dit on va se lancer sur le circuit
on va voir ce que ça donne
et puis c'est comme ça que j'ai commencé
à jouer ce qu'on appelle les tournois
professionnels et alors vos grands
souvenirs évidemment c'est laisser les
tournois du grand chelem chez vous alors
il ya eu les tournois du grand chelem
mais il ya aussi surtout la fed cup où
j'ai eu la chance de participer et de
jouer pour l'équipe de france d'entendre
la marseillaise c'était quelque chose de
très fort et puis j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir comme capitaine et un certain
yannick noah alors vous avez vous êtes
de grands sportifs qui est que réussie
nuit après la la carrière sportive
puisque vous êtes aujourd'hui sur rmc
jeudi vous animez les grandes gueules du
sport tous les week-ends comme on sait
comment c'est venu ça coco vous avez
pensé pendant que vous étiez encore au
très haut niveau à ce que vous feriez
après alors les premières questions il
arrive souvent quand on a le temps d'y
penser et c'est souvent quand les
blessures arrivent dire que on est
tellement dans dans son entraînement
dans ses programmes qu'on ne le voit pas
venir et à ma première blessure et bien
je me suis dit puisque j'ai six mois
d'arrêt je vais aller me forme et j'ai
frappé à la porte d'une radio dit est ce
que vous voulez bien m'expliquer comment
ça fonctionne et c'est comme ça que j'ai
été piqué au virus de la radio et à la
fin de ma carrière j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer les gens qui m'ont fait
confiance et qui m'ont dit est ce que ça
vous dit de venir qu'on se tourne
d'abord et un consultant d'abord et puis
après une émission qui a marqué un
certain nombre c'est c'était une
émission qui s'appelait décaper avec
alexandre delpérier geek et dia et je
faisais le pks qui est ça a été ma
première expérience radio et depuis bas
gg voilà depuis je n'ai pas arrêté
alors il faut qu'on parle a aussi un
petit peu de golf parce que c'est devenu
quelque chose d'important dans votre vie
puisque vous participez alors plutôt
dans le secteur de la communication à
l'organisation de certains grand nombre
de tournois de l'open de france
notamment du trophée des légendes
on va on va en parler o peut-être se
garer pions allait peut-être marcher un
petit peu
qu'est ce que vous faites par exemple
pour l'open de france
le principe en fait c'est c'est
d'intéresser les médias au golf c'est de
trouver tous les leviers qui fait qu'on
peut raconter des histoires autour du
golf alors pas nécessairement les
joueurs mais c'est l'histoire du golf
national là où il a été construit
c'est l'histoire de ce parcours qui
évolue depuis deux ans en prévision de
l'accueil de la ryder cup
donc voilà c'est s'est trouvé trouvé
plein de petites histoires qui fait que
les médias français vont s'intéresser à
ce sport qui est qui reste encore
peut-être un petit peu confidentiel mais
c'est d'ouvrir donc en fait voilà c'est
ça notre rôle donc plus je je traite sur
l'école que je rencontre des gens plus à
m'alimenter et ça permet de trouver des
histoires ce que je propose aux médias
il va y avoir un événement assez génial
je crois au moment de pâques de france
pour faire parler d'eux de ce trophée
des légendes qui aura lieu en septembre
prochain
oui cirque en a on a décidé de faire une
opération qui va qui va un petit peu
dénoter c'est c'est d'inviter des
légendes du sport de tous les sports qui
ont une fibre un peu golf parce que
finalement il ya beaucoup de sportifs
oui je sais on dit aux gars et de les
inviter sur une péniche pour frapper des
balles sur la scène des balles
biodégradables bien évidemment on va pas
laisser les balles traîner au fin fond
de la scène en compagnie bas des ddd
grand champion de golf donc faire une
une petite réunion en disant bayou rôle
agent vous les sportifs et ben play with
one merci beaucoup aux arts à pittsburgh
ce qui alors j'appelle donc les grandes
gueules c'est tous les week-ends sur rmc
oh vous entoure et évidemment sur bfm tv
comme consultante en matière de tennis
et puis et puis il ya la matière de golf
l'open de france le tournoi des légendes
alors il ya une petite épreuve quand
même dans cette émission vous y jouer au
golf et je joue je joue à tout gosse je
joue à tout rigole oui pas plus et comme
tous les grands de bon
de tennis d'une bonne dose de gaulle pas
disons qu'il ya une gestuelle après
l'efficacité c'est tout autre chose
alors l'épreuve c'est qu'on va me faire
swinguer un peu et puis on soumettra
votre swing à un pro qui vous dira voilà
ce que vous pourriez corrigé il trouve
les trouve toujours des défauts toute
façon donc qu'est-ce que vous les mêmes
pour vous y aura sans doute des défauts
à trouver avais je vais me préparer
j'espère que j'aurai une petite fiche
avec les points d'amélioration à faire
ils venaient de tout ça merci beaucoup
ça va le but de costil
merci beaucoup pour l'invitation
[Musique]
et pour analyser le swing de sarah
pitkowski on va retrouver notre propre
référé comme d'habitude
eh ben c'est toujours sébastien russie
on s'est rendu compte qu'en fait en
discutant qu'il ya un petit problème de
contacts notamment sur la conception sur
la manière dont on prend la balle
comprendre comment on va transmettre de
l'énergie du club à la balle voilà est
sorti un peu de frustration qui fait
qu'on met plein d'efforts ça se traduit
pas par une trajectoire intéressante
donc déjà faire attention à ça ensuite
ça qu'on a dit moi ce que je voyais tu
vas c'était un mouvement qui a un peu
trop centrés où tu joues un peu qu'avec
les bras est à des bonnes qualités
physiques
il faut absolument que tu les utilisent
et je pense que ça va te permettre
d'arriver à créer plus de vitesse
d'énergie tu vois donc on a parlé
principalement de la rotation et de son
pivot qui était un petit peu insuffisant
avec finalement pas de mise en tension
musculaire ce qui l'obligé à forcer un
peu la descente pour générer de
l'énergie et donc je vais simplement
demander en fait je n'ai un petit
exercice qu'on a fait tout à l'heure
avec le petit stick où on place le club
à l'instar du pied droit on en est un
autre sur les épaules comme ceux ci et
on vient confondre les deux clubs au
sommet du swing simplement
donc il y avait ça pour quantifier un
peu la rotation savoir si effectivement
bas elle était bien suffisamment en a qu
à droite il n'y avait pas trop de
déplacement latéral donc ça lui permet
d'atteindre un ratio qui est intéressant
au niveau de la posture on a essayé de
recaler certains angles et puis au fur
et à mesure de la séance on s'est rendu
compte que l avait plus de confort en
tout cas on est en haut du corps un tout
petit peu plus en avant plus de
stabilité de facilité à trouver le point
bas du mouvement voilà donc on
améliorées principalement la rotation
qui on a parlé de la cinématique de
descente leurs banques qu'elles se font
les choses au golf pour que ce soit une
réaction en chaîne ce qu'ils demandent
finalement très peu d'énergie pour
envoyer la balle très loin et qui donne
ce côté très agréable en fait c'est
exactement il donc si de comprendre la
réaction en chaîne
la réaction en chaîne et soit pas cassée
voilà du coup ça ravel a l'impression
que il fallait toucher le sol pour
décoller la balle et on voit que si on a
tendance à faire plus tôt ce genre de
mouvement la balle est frappée avec le
tranchant du club ce qui est un très
mauvais coup évidemment donc de manière
à jeu expliquait simplement
qu'effectivement le club devait arriver
très légèrement descendant avec les
faire pour que ce soit bien
effectivement le sweet spot ici qui se
présente en premier et qu'on puisse la
toucher donc on va plutôt être dans une
attaque qui est un peu balle terre
travail ça déjà tu as un rat pour le
contact a vu que ça permettait d'arriver
à transmettre de l'énergie efficacement
la balle de clore ces balles qui partent
à droite et après tu vas vraiment
chercher un peu plus d'an roulement
musculaire venir charger un peu plus à
droite simplement pas avoir peur de
mettre un peu plus de pression au niveau
du pied droit pour qu'elle soit
également plus naturel de transférer
tournée du cas je peux utiliser mon bas
du corps ce que je suis à l'aise je suis
plutôt à l'aise avec avec le bas du
corps avec mon cerveau exactement
merci ok moi je t'en prie écouter avec
plaisir
[Musique]
non
dans ce numéro 2 par soixante dix huit
je vous propose de découvrir un très
joli golf qui se situe sur la commune de
plaisir c'est le golfe isabella et pour
en parler je vais rejoindre son
président pierre bruneau de la salle
pierre de la salle bonjour vous êtes
présidente du golfe isabella qui situe
sur la commune de plaisir alors on va
dire d'avoir un mot peut-être de de ce
nouveau formidable prénoms de femmes
golf ça vient d'où alors ça vient d'eux
en fait de l'origine de ceux de ce club
puisque cette propriété sur laquelle a
été fait le parcours appartenait
appartient toujours d'ailleurs à la
famille adhère donc en 69 ils ont fait
les neuf trous donc la caractéristique
de ce club est un peu demeuré c'est à
dire c'est une bande de copains qui ont
commencé à à démarrer ensuite à faire
venir d'autres amis et en ces temps dans
les années quatre-vingt neuf qui sont
passés à 18 trous ce qui ce qui est le
cas aujourd'hui avec beaucoup de travaux
sur presque tout à l'heure en fait
pourquoi isabella c'est que la femme de
monsieur à dire s'appelait isabelle et
lui a donné le nom de
ça commence très bien comme histoire et
toute la famille une bonne partie de la
famille khadr joue encore avec nous golf
isabella on dit d'ailleurs dès hier golf
isabelle hénon golf d'isabelle alors il
ya une particularité dans ce golfe y en
a d'autres facettes d'une des grandes
particularités c'est que c'est un golf
associatif voilà c'est un golf privé
associatif si vous voulez nous louons le
terrain à la famille y adhèrent c'est
l'association qui gère l'ensemble du
golfe alors ça veut dire
nous vivons essentiellement des
cotisations de nos membres et 7 ouvert
aussi en partie pour des greens fille
extérieur mais aussi aux amis des
membres mais cela doive
téléphoner à l'avant si vous les gars
alors oui parce qu'il ya une
particularité pour les membres je crois
c'est que y'a pas un vrai repas de
départ on est toujours sur un peu près
de partir voilà ils avaient la même tout
le temps n'y avait pas de possibilité de
réserver en fait il n'ya pas de planning
donc si vous s'il faut vérifier
simplement qu'ils aient pas de
compétition le jour où on est
normalement dans le quart d'heure vous
êtes parti parce que si vous êtes tout
seul il ya deux qui partent il veut dire
ils lisent ou les jouer avec nous
en général c'est un quart d'heure vingt
minutes maximum si vous n'avez pas
réservé on dit toujours oui c'est un
gosse dans lequel on vit bien où les
gens viennent en famille sont assez
ouverts les autres fait exactement ça on
a essayé de conserver le caractère
amical convivial qui était à la base du
club si vous voulez donc une école de
golf où on a entre 60 et 80 jeunes
oui tous les deux fois par semaine il ya
même
garderie peau parce que les parents qui
ont 40 ans des jeunes enfants s'ils
peuvent pas laisser la garderie peuvent
pas jouer donc tout ça très cordiale
c'est aussi ça le fasse aussi hâtif
c'est que voilà on est en
il faut se sentir bien quoi il faut se
sentir bien et un peu se sentir
responsables de son club
aussi je vous ai entendu dire justement
que voilà il ya des quelques manques
comme ça qu'ils ont qui sont
responsables par exemple c'est bien ça
veut dire que chaque mois vous êtes 500
à peu près on est au total 500 et
sachant que membre actif qui joue pour
nous un peu près 400 20 430 si vous
voulez donc les 420 930 qui joue soit
impliqué dans la vie du parcours vita
correctement alors justement le parcours
disiez tout à l'heure dans les années 80
il est passé de 9 à 18 trous et puis il
ya chaque année et même récemment failli
pas mal de travaux d'aménagement
d'amélioration alaoui depuis quelques
années on a fait coûterait de très gros
travaux en fait alors d'une part il y
avait eu tout le drainage du parcours
qu'avait été refait
a maintenant une dizaine d'années et
puis le club que vous verrez parce qu'il
était assez anciens donc on l'a non
seulement rénové mais a grandi
considérablement et le parcours depuis
deux trois ans et s'est considérablement
améliorée et maintenant on arrive à
accepter enfin même à faire venir des
des compétitions de ligue des
compétitions et c'est là il ya trois
semaines on avait la cdd sélection des
championnats de france des jeunes
pendant trois jours ici si vous voulez
donc maintenant le parcours on peut on
sans jeu organisé un grand prix un pro
am on a et puis peut-être c'est vrai que
l'arrivée de la ryder cup la ryder cup
on va essayer de participer à ces
journées en train de voir comment
comment pour aider la fédération et nous
mêmes aussi ma bravo en tout cas parce
que ce par quoi est magnifique il et on
voit pourquoi qui les îles et les
moments sont un peu amoureux bravo et
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
jouer au golf ça demande du temps or
vous n'avez peut-être pas 4 ou 5 heures
devant vous alors est ce qu'il est
possible de jouer une heure ou une heure
et demie au golf sur un parcours
eh bien oui grâce à une nouvelle société
une start up qui s'appelle eagle et on
va rencontrer son créateur olivier
d'hôtel olivier d'hôtel bonjour bonjour
à 13 est le co fondateur d'une société
dont on peut dire une start up qui
s'appelle eagle eux j'ai vécu deux ailes
alors vous êtes parti d'une idée qui est
qui est vrai c'est que les gens pas
forcément 4h04 réduit pour jouer au golf
et l à quoi sert eagle la rigole sert
vraiment à favoriser la fréquence de jeu
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que le golf
est le seul sport qui ne peut pas se
pratiquer en une heure pour faire une
heure de yoga une heure de tennis une
heure de fitness danse jogging mais pas
une heure de golf sauf au practice
alors ce mot practice muhlbach actis ce
que nous ont dit les joueurs c'est que
c'est quand même un petit peu ennuyeux à
la longue
donc avec notre système de paiement au
trou ça veut dire que vous avez une
heure trente devant vous pouvez partir
sur le golf et vous allez être facturé
uniquement le nombre de trous que vous
allez jouer réellement à la relève des
hôtels il faut expliquer comment ça
marche
il ya une application de eagle qu'on
peut télécharger commencera sur un
smartphone absolument alors c'est
l'application s'appelle eagle paix comme
pour payer vous la télécharger vous
créez un compte
vous allez voir la liste des parcours
qui fonctionne avec eagle paix par ordre
de proximité vous allez réserver par
téléphone
votre parcours on va vous donner un code
à l'accueil qui va vous donner
l'autorisation d'aller sur le parcours
vous jouez cinq trous six trous
aujourd'hui les premiers golfeurs qui
utilisent notre service joue en moyenne
7 trulli et vous vous arrêtez exactement
quand vous voulez une fois que vous avez
terminé vous sortez du parcours et là
vous vous arrêtez l'application qui
traque en fait le golfeur grâce au gps
du mobile sur les bases sur le golf et
on vous dit vous avez joué sept trous
voilà vous nous devez 25 euros avec donc
il n'y a pas de possibilité de tricher
dia voilà je voudrais jouer un quart
d'heure et de rester quatre heures
seulement au prénom vous
traces et je peux dire exactement et
pour les petits malins qui voudraient
tenter d'arrêter la publication au cours
de route de smartphones ont les factures
plein pot à vrai dire un 18 trous est en
fait la partie ne peut se terminer que
lorsque vous sortez du parcours et que
vous êtes proche du club house la
société toute récente
oui là deux ans et demi seulement vous
aurez mis le service à un mois à moi
donc c'est tout récent donc il n'ya pas
encore tous les golfs de france qui
écrit son kiki aucun passé un accord
avec vous il ya pour l'instant le golf
national absolument les golfs de
bluegreen comme un exactement c'est toi
et c'est ça on est très très content de
l'accueil des golfs parce que ça répond
à un problème économique
ça répond à un problème de mode de vie
on s'aperçoit que les gens n'ont pas
forcément 4h30 a joué sur toutes les
semaines et puis ça répond aussi à un
usage de flexibilité on offre de la
flexibilité de la liberté au golfeur
comme n'importe quel autre sportif peut
avoir aujourd'hui et on était allé
interroger tous les golfeurs qu'on a vu
lors de les viandes championship l'année
dernière en 2016 et 80% d'entre nous ont
dit oui ça nous intéresse ça nous
intéresse parce qu'on aimerait jouer
entre midi et deux ça nous intéresse
parce qu'on aimerait jouer le soir après
le boulot ça nous intéresse en
remplacement d'une séance au practice
pour faire quelques trous avec mes
enfants etc etc
donc on s'est dit il ya tellement humble
avis il ya le savoir il ya un trou dans
la pyramide des âges des golfeurs entre
environ 25 ans et 45 ans qui correspond
à quoi à l'entrée dans la vie active à
l'achat d'une maison au mariage des
enfants et reprennent pas quand ils sont
à peu installée donc du coup nous on
pense que notre solution va pouvoir
dynamiser redynamiser ces gens là et
puis certainement attirer de nouveaux
joueurs des débutants qui se disent
tiens là maintenant j'ai une solution
flexible et peut-être pas très onéreuse
pour aller jouer au golf et il n'y a pas
d'abonnement pour avoir l'application
l'application est gratuite l'application
est gratuite exactement et le service
est gratuit pour les golfs puisque c'est
eux qui fixent les tarifs c'est eux qui
fixent les créneaux horaires disponibles
pour jouer à roue et c'est un outil
marketing pour attirer des golfeurs
plus nombreux et plus fréquemment c'est
génial retrait merci bravo merci
beaucoup aller bravo pour cette
obligation j'ai vraiment ça oui c'est
extrêmement nouveau et c'est la preuve
encore une fois qu'il ya quelques
startups qui s'intéressent au golf et ça
c'est la preuve tous aient couru moss
portait encore moderne
exactement merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
et pour cette émission je vous propose
de faire un gros plan sur une
compétition qui a eu lieu au golf
national l'international golf week
né à l'intérieur de cet international
golf righi à plusieurs compétitions donc
là deux cailloux golf cup et c'est en
compagnie de stéphane de cailloux
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le pdg de la
société de cailloux alors aura peut-être
un petit bout sur cette société qui
travaille beaucoup avec l'industrie du
luxe
oui absolument c'est une vieille société
qui a été créée en 1911 par un
arrière-grand-oncle donc il ya plus de
100 ans qui compte environ 600 personnes
sur neuf sites de production est
spécialisé dans la fabrication de
composants métalliques pour d'autres
industries et en particulier pour le
monde du luxe la joaillerie la
maroquinerie en particulier est au plus
haut depuis quelques temps vous avez
ajouter une autre corde si je peux dire
votre axe ce sont des vêtements
notamment pour le golf comme eux comme
cette chemise ou celui des accessoires
aussi absolument j'ai créé cette marque
il ya quatre ans à peine pour
effectivement vendre créer et vendre des
produits accessoires de luxe pour les
amoureux du golf que je suis oui c'est
ça je suppose que vous aimez le golf etc
c'est pour ça aussi que vous êtes lancés
dans cette de cette entreprise alors là
vous êtes supporter de cette compétition
vous êtes supporter de plusieurs
d'ailleurs compétition à travers la
france pourquoi sponsorisés d'aider des
compositions de golf
en fait on a créé cette marque qui est
un peu particulière puisque on fait des
accessoires de luxe personnalisables
pour les amoureux du golf et on nous
n'avons pas de concurrence donc il faut
créer le marché il faut se faire
connaître et nous avons décidé de nous
mettre en relation d'avoir des
partenariats avec les plus beaux golfs
français pour démarrer à l'étranger
ensuite et pour se faire connaître nous
faisons une compétition dans chacun de
ces golfs partenaires et les 50 plus
beaux en france cette année voilà c'est
pour ça que nous sommes au golf national
les eaux qui alors qu'ils viennent
participer cette compétition est
d'ailleurs très bien reçue il faut dire
ça il ya deux options aux cadeaux c'est
ça fait aussi partie de cet intérêt se
gausse week
absolument
on fait on fait plus nous-mêmes pour
l'adopter yougov cup plus de 8000 euros
de dotation par compétition avec des
très beaux lots être sponsor de golf
alors ça permet de faire parler d'une
marque de travailler l'image de cette
bac ça permet aussi peut-être d'acquérir
de nouveaux clients contre d une jeune
marque comme la voûte
bien sûr c'est le but c'est le but de se
faire connaître et bien sûr de vendre
des produits puisque on dépense beaucoup
donc on veut récupérer beaucoup de
nouveaux clients et espère connaître
chez tous ces golfeurs qui apprécient
cette journée vous même vous êtes un bon
joueur de golf moyens j'ai été meilleur
que je ne suis en ce moment je ne sais
pas pourquoi mais j'ai joué un peu moins
bien ce que ça s'est bien passé quand
même aujourd'hui c'est toujours plus à
un plaisir formidable de jouer sur le
parcours de l'albatros donc oui c'était
c'était très bien donc je rappelle va
stéphane de cailloux pdg de la société
de cailloux kit spots sort un nouveau
sponsor on peut dire dans le monde du
golf
merci beaucoup merci à vous cet homme
est absolument incroyable il s'appelle
d'avril et loire s'est fait des choses
insensées avec des clubs venus d'on ne
sait où il fait chaud dedans tout dans
toutes les grandes épreuves notamment au
vu de la ryder cup nationale aurait dit
à m
la ceas je pense que c'est un endroit
formidable c'est super d'être ici de
faire le spectacle pour les gens un
véritable magicien du golfe avec sa
collection de club il fait disparaître
les balles le golfeur américain david
edwards joue de sa technique pour un
spectacle sur le green de saint quentin
en yvelines devant une cinquantaine de
personnes
ce que j'ai vu c'est un extraterrestre
et quand on joue au golf déjà joué à peu
près bien c'est tellement difficile
voilà il ya du monde entre nous il m'a
proposé de faire le concours de dry avec
un team et sur un shaft et c'est vrai
que sur le coup zimbabwe ça va le faire
mais en fait non ça ne fait pas du tout
parce que même si on sait jouer au golf
c'est pas quelque chose d'évident du
tout comme un jouet citez moi je pensais
pas ça je pensais qu'il faisait du coup
pas aussi le csaj tout ça avec un driver
de deux mètres un pavé utilisé comme
outil ou un mélange entre golf et tennis
david edwards propose une palette de
styles ici pas de stratagèmes l'artiste
sort les tire de son chapeau un moment
de partage avec les spectateurs
j'aime bien m'amuser avec les gens tu
arrives à les renvoyer chez eux avec le
sourire tu arrives à partager une part
de ce super jeu avec eux peu importe que
tu sois vieux ou jeunes tout le monde
peut devenir le meilleur aujourd'hui on
sait que joueur mais pas seulement le
showman se lance dans une série
d'imitations du golfeur espagnol miguel
angel jiménez au président américain
donald trump
un spectacle pour donner une leçon de
golf sur le ton de l'humour c'est le
secret quand vous jouez à ce jeu et de
ne pas avoir des leçons de golf et ne
pas s'entraîner vous avez les leçons
mais vous avez les entraînements mais
sortez de ce cadre pour prendre du
plaisir et si vous prenez du plaisir
dans ce jour en jour et mios gauche
[Applaudissements]
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
très vite pour un nouveau numéro 2 par
[Musique]